[Applaudissements]
pourquoi toi et moi destiné
inutile de fuir ou de lutter les
sous-doués ah ouais qu'est-ce que vous
avez marqué ce film carton gigantesque
mais oui et encore aujourd'hui mais oui
c'est culture merci Monsieur Claudy j'ai
jamais fait de cinéma faisait du théâtre
et du théâtre d'auteur voilà j'avais
joué 18 pièces dans dans ma Belgique
natale et puis je
termine ma première année de classe
libre au cours Florent et
Monsieur cardan nous avait prêté son
théâtre pour passer
une une édition publique et
le lendemain je reviens en cours et il y
a François Florent qui me dit viens un
peu par ici toi
je me dis oh là là
dis donc le téléphone n'arrête pas de
sonner pour toi il y a 9 agents qui te
veulent j'y mets moi je ne savais pas ce
que c'était un agent artistique alors je
dis mais je commence par lequel le plus
mauvais comme ça ça va taguer rire et
puis et puis j'avais évidemment ramené
mes coupures de presse belle journée
les planches et vous n'aviez jamais fait
de cinéma quand Claude
je devais me donner la réplique à
moi-même
ce film était avant-gardiste c'est
l'émission M6 alors encore ton premier
regard Isa avait inventé le Love
computer on met une machine sur la tête
on chante et on voit si ça fait bip ou
pas oui je vous promets s'il vous plaît
je sais que vous êtes amoureuse mais je
sais aussi que vous savez ressentir ce
que l'amour oui je vais vous faire
danser jusqu'à 15 secondes avec trois
personnes dites-moi si un fluide
[Applaudissements]
si vous voulez
on y va vraiment avec grâce vous gardez
l'eau
le pantalon vous gardez on roule je ne
sais pas on commence par destiné est-ce
que l'amour est ici le Love computer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup ne bougez
pas merci Jean-Michel candidat suivants
à la fin pour vous si vous avez vu que
ça passe bien mais je ne réclame du
choix
quand même attention
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup alors attention
alors vous ne me dites rien pour le
moment et parle avec toi
alors en dernier
je veux d'abord je suis désolé je suis
désolé il y a un peu gris un peu
moins décédé
un peu
Lolo
[Applaudissements]
quand ça suffit ça suffit je rentre
mais quoi
[Applaudissements]
j'aurais dû mettre des hauts talent pour
être à la hauteur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous arrêtez pas la musique c'était
parti moi
[Applaudissements]
alors j'ai une interview vous faire mais
quand même si vous deviez en choisir et
pas franchement là
j'ai senti un peu de chance
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la femme de Candeloro vient d'apprendre
que un il peut se barrer gratte le
Capitani et que deux il me dit chez moi
pour une première expérience homosexuel
elle est contente
alors j'ajouterai que la chanson à la
servi au soudée en vacances mais aussi
dans le Père Noël est une ordure
absolument et il en peut plus d'ailleurs
le pauvre alors question on avance un
petit peu donc c'est un film qui ouvre
les portes après ça des films formidable
avec Michel Galabru des séries et les
ripoux
les ripoux
ça a vraiment oui il était formidable
Thierry Lhermitte aussi et au lit il
était très très correct ce qui paraît
que Noiret pas aimable dans la mais on
m'avait préparé le terrain
de mon père dans une série avant qui m'a
dit mais il paraît que tu vas tourner
avec noir et je dis oui mais il est
comment t'inquiète je t'ai préparé le
terrain
les ripoux énormes cartons je crois
qu'il y a trois César et là oui trois
César on aurait pu en avoir un quatrième
avec la musique mais là où Claude Zidi
est vraiment quelqu'un de formidable
c'est qu'il a changé l'histoire du
cinéma français
c'était la première fois qu'une comédie
et trois César
pas mis c'était le moins bon je vous le
dise
alors après 2017 on retrouve sur la 6
avec scène de ménage
là pareil alors peut-être qu'il a un peu
moins de talent que Philippe Noiret mais
il a le même caractère visiblement ça
passe pas le genre bien Guigui
sur le tournage
on est connu des touts vraiment des bons
et des qui pouvaient m'impressionner
mais ils ont tous un point en commun à
part le talent bien évidemment c'est
l'humilité d'accord
et à part il y a une autre que j'avais
Guigui comme ça qui vous a déçu
proposer de me faire divorcer et puis de
de venir avec un homme plus jeune
puisque les cougars sont à la mode oh
mais dis donc
vous êtes des gens en couple on va
parler
libre visiblement
alors non mais il y a d'autres acteurs
qui s'étaient difficile de tourner
honnêtement il paraît que tient la mite
par exemple est très drôle à l'antenne
mais il est très très dans la vie ah il
était très très bien parce que quand on
était au lit on gardait les tags on
gardait le jean et puis il se mettait
sûrement il me disait ça va je suis pas
trop lourd non parce que
embrasser quelqu'un au cinéma vous
pouvez vous retrouver avec un bifteck
comme ça dans la bouche non
est-ce que vous vous souvenez que dans
une destinée vous deviez apprendre à
chanter en japonais Guy Marchand qui
s'est tourné en japonais
mytana hashigaoui
my Tanaka
[Musique]
ça reste pas mais c'était en 1981 ouais
bah les textes ça se retient je suis
désolé
[Musique]
merci pour cette intervention
pour vous c'est vrai qu'on vous a tout à
l'heure vous parlez de Cougar vous aimez
bien les garçons un petit peu plus
jeunes personne peut vous le reprocher
ils sont majeurs et vous aime bien aussi
parce que vous êtes très belle on vous
apprêtez la relation avec
combien de temps
deux heures
avec lui ah oui un an et demi
cashermit que j'ai 3e oui que j'ai eu ma
première maison d'édition mais non
Ramsay incroyable incroyable incroyable
comme ça qu'est-ce qu'il y a ah ben
partir un jour oui bah là et votre
premier mari dont vous étiez très
amoureuse et fidèle en revanche lui vous
l'avez quitté parce qu'il était infidèle
c'est lui qui m'a quitté il était
infidèle en plus il vous a trompé et
vous a quitté oui il me trompait souvent
et puis il a fini par me quitter et je
crois que c'est horrible la manière dont
vous l'avez découvert mais ça peut je
sais pour que je vous en parle parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est le plus gros fléau
les gens trompent
osent pas dire qu'ils ont se remettent
en couple et ramène des mauvaises choses
si vous voulez ce que je veux dire parce
qu'ils ont pas osé et c'est ce qui vous
est arrivé il était d'une beauté
stupéfiant oui mais ça n'empêche pas
donc il a été voir ailleurs grâce à sa
beauté j'ai fait deux enfants
merveilleux très beau aussi bon très
bien mais je regroupe pas l'anecdote
mais c'est vrai qu'il est parti on va
dire en voyage il est revenu et vous
êtes retrouvé avec une petite
MST et vous êtes bien douté que comme
vous vous alliez pas voir ailleurs
c'était lui ah ça je me souviens plus ah
c'est vrai pourtant vous l'avez raconté
rien des trucs qui sont qu'on a pas
envie d'y penser non mais vous savez
pourquoi je le dis parce que il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de gens aujourd'hui et
c'est vrai sur les MST sur le sida et
tout ça ça se passe beaucoup comme ça
c'est quelqu'un qui trompe qui n'ose pas
dire à la personne qui l'a trompé qui
revient et qui leur file le truc donc ça
c'est
oui mais quand on agit mal il faut avoir
du courage
c'est pour ça que j'ai dit pas mal
on attaque si je vous dis promotion
canapé ça vous penser à quoi
un film alors
un bon souvenir excellent ah merde
excellent parce que déjà les films à
Paris sortent le mercredi et c'était un
film sur le harcèlement sexuel n'a
absolument donc les lois à l'Assemblée
nationale sont votés le mercredi le jour
du Tour du du premier jour la loi sort
mais on peut pas voir de meilleures pub
non et vraiment pas cher